what if the stories you remember
changed in a way you'd never forget
t'challa what if the heroes you knew
became something larger than life on
august 11th
expect the unexpected
that's weird and ask yourself the
question
what if streaming august 11th
only on disney plus you know the stories
but what if one thing changed
everything that doesn't sound ominous at
all on august 11th
expect the unexpected it cannot be
let's be honest we've been through
weirder
and ask yourself the question what if
it appears we have a common enemy i
guess i have to freestyle then
streaming august 11th only on disney
plus
yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a
job with peace
do we know each other
time
[Music]
reality reality
[Music]
it's changeable
where you want to be
that's the question isn't it every
universe
different each one
[Music]
slow down a little bit there's a few
people in the room that don't understand
not me i i get it
who are you the name's captain carter
[Music]
scheisse i am the watcher
i observe all that transpires here
but i do not cannot will not interfere
i guess i have to freestyle then
hey we have you out of bird a ravager
never flies solo
i said never flies solo
is that some kind of catchphrase
you had me wear it for a second
journey to face the unknown and ponder
the question
[Music]
what if
you